you
when I'm depressed it's trying to do
anything feels like trying to start a
car when there's no gas in the car
you can like really want to go somewhere
you can really want to like do the thing
but you'd literally don't have the means
you know it can feel as heavy as a
boulder or as like to carry around as my
fingernail but it's as much a part of me
as that fingernail is impression to me
feels like a giant weight kind of like
one of those big dumbbells it starts
like right in your gut and you just feel
it slowly intensifying so it starts out
small and then all of a sudden it gets a
little bit bigger a little bit bigger it
goes down to your stomach it goes up to
your heart it kind of spreads throughout
your entire body and it just gets like
slowly heavier and heavier and just a
little bit harder to deal with and a
little bit harder to carry and then it
gets really overwhelming
having anxiety feels like a million
bubbles filled with things that could go
wrong that are just pushing on me and
each bubble is filled with something
that could go wrong and all of the
things that could go wrong are
irrational to a normal person but to
someone with anxiety the thing that
could go wrong it feels like the worst
thing in the world it kind of feels like
rolling in a ball down a hill you do
start to feel like a little bit like a
roll equality and you just kind of
collapse in on yourself and like one
little kind of thing that you get
fixated on and then it just kind of
starts to kind of spin and spin and spin
around you until you kind of feel like
you can't control all the things that
are wearing you anymore
I have obsessive-compulsive disorder and
to me that's always felt like having a
separate sort of cloud of a mind outside
of my own mind sort of buzzing gray hive
of thoughts that sort of come in and out
of my own brain and can be sort of busy
or a less busy depending on how I'm
feeling on the day OCD is like a faucet
tripping over and over and over again
and you keep having all these irrational
thoughts and you know they're irrational
but you just keep having them and they
are so important to you at that moment
and it's all led by fear
ATD feels kind of like being this like
high-functioning robot but if you like
went into the mind of the robot and
actually learned what the robot is
thinking it's just like a bunch of Katy
Perry songs and like old childhood
memories it has this huge importance to
you this is the thing that actually
impacts many many many people but people
don't actually do anything about it
because we are trained to think that
it's not a problem or it's something
that we can control when sometimes it
actually isn't there's a lot of beauty
that can come out of it there are
strengths to it for sure and I think a
lot of creative people especially have
figured out ways to connect ideas and
use it in a creative sort of way